[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 182 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I
am Jonathan fellows and I'm here with my
colleague Michelle kazman hey Michelle
how are you doing hey Jon I'm great how
are you I'm doing pretty well it's a
really long week but I'm really excited
for a lot of things that are happening
this week in e3 and I'm really excited
to hear what you guys have to talk about
today with Paco nathan from darwin ai
Paco will tell us a little bit about the
work he's doing an AI big data and cloud
and a little bit about bias in ml and we
are joined by a special guests Amanda
Kesari so that seems exciting it was a
really great segment to do I'm pretty
excited to hear how it turned out
awesome well you have a bunch of cool
things for the week but I will tease the
question of the week which is last week
we got to see stadia connect and it
answered a bunch of questions that
developers have had at our gaming
conferences that Marc and I have been
attending so I'll be going into a little
bit of the detail that we got to hear
there all right but first let's talk
about the coolest things of the week
[Applause]
John what was the coolest thing about
this week CERN recreated the Higgs
discovery on GCP yeah
you might have a little bit more detail
on that yeah so this actually happened a
couple weeks ago so I am just getting
back from my trip to Europe where I got
to visit CERN in person I was really
blown away I went to cube con Barcelona
and there were a few engineers up on
stage they gave a keynote where they
recreated the discovery of the Higgs
boson on Google Cloud so we'll link to a
video check it out it was really amazing
they essentially reproduced the entire
discovery within I believe it was four
to five minutes on stage you can see
that happening but what was really cool
is being able to visit in person
obviously so after I got to see it on
stage CERN is such a good partner for a
Google cloud because they've always had
this open data policy but before public
clouds existed they weren't really sure
so not many people could really do
anything with the data sets that they
uploaded because not many people had
access to the types of data centers that
they have access to so if you are
interested in discovering pigs yourself
they've uploaded that entire data set
check out the CERN open data portal if
you want to recreate their experiment on
your own but I wanted to share some
really fun facts I got to visit Atlas
which is one of seven experiments there
are seven in total four main experiments
Atlas is a general-purpose experiment
it's the largest and I didn't get to see
these other ones but there's also CMS
also general purpose Elise LHCb and a
few other ones so it was really
interesting to see it in person to see
what a Collider looks like when it's a
few feet in front of you but some of the
really cool things I learned the Large
Hadron Collider was built on the French
Swiss border and so the border actually
runs right across the property and the
majority of the LHC is actually on the
French side and what's interesting about
that when you go to visit if you want to
get money out of a Swiss ATM you can
only do that on one side of the property
because Swiss banks it only exists
within Switzerland
the other cool thing that I liked did
you know that CERN was the birthplace of
the web I did not actually know that so
I got to visit the building where it all
began so I got to see the data center
there are some very large
transcontinental interconnects that
essentially end at CERN
I was really need to be there so not
only was it the site of the announcement
of the Higgs particle but also birth of
the web whoa yeah it was a really
interesting space to be in but my sort
of burning question for this physicist I
could ask her anything and the question
that I ask is the Large Hadron Collider
takes protons and it sends them off in
two opposing directions so that they
collide together and my question was
where do the protons come from that
these beams are composed of and her
answer was it's a canister of hydrogen
and there's some really interesting math
behind that it's a really small canister
like the size of maybe your forearm so
very small you can actually see it in
person if you go to visit and that will
essentially power the LHC in perpetuity
so I'll add a link to some of the math
but it's essentially just taking
hydrogen atoms splitting them up so that
they're just a single proton and sending
them on a collision course I thought
that was really interesting I expected
some very complicated process for like
yanking protons out but it's actually
very simple nice I can tell by the
excitement of your voice that you had a
really good time and for our listeners
can you tell them what CERN actually
stands for just in case none of them
actually know yeah I believe it's the
European Center for Nuclear Research so
they're doing high-energy physics
smashing protons together so the Higgs
discovery was so important because it
helps us understand what happened after
the Big Bang helps us to understand the
world around us and they're doing some
really important research there if you
want to follow up again the open data
portal if you want to look at any of
their data sets that's a good place to
start
also they sent a Google Streetview
camera through there so if you want to
see what the CERN control center looks
like you can do that via Street View
it's a really cool perspective but also
one of the best ways to see it is to
watch the documentary called particle
fever that was one of my first
introductions
CERN is watching the video and that
essentially it's a documentary of the
explanation of the announcement of the
Higgs particle I thought that was really
interesting that's cool
do you happen to know which GCP products
you're using when they recreated the
discovery yeah they describe it all in
the video and I believe they were using
Google Cloud Storage kubernetes engine
and memory store is the other GCP
product that they're using and what I
didn't know I figured this out at cube
con when I spoke with them afterwards
they're also using cube Flo did you know
that CERN has been using cube flow for
over a year they're one of our oldest
users actually they didn't know that
actually and next staff the cube Flo
poof and that's where I got my first
introduction to cute Flo so it's kind of
amazing to see that CERN is actually
using cube flow for recreating this
discovery it's kind of Awesome yeah and
I'm very excited so that's part of why I
was there because I went and I talked to
them about some of their newer cuteville
uses and they have some really really
exciting ideas and I'm hoping to be able
to work with them in the future to do
even more with the platform sorry
cutting well Michelle that was
definitely awesome so let's just jump
right in with Paco and our surprise
guests Amanda and see what you guys
talked about and next a couple months
back so let's hear what they have to say
[Music]
huge welcome to a few of our guests
today we have Paco Nathan managing
partner for Derwin AI and we also have
Amanda Kesari here she's an engineer on
Google cloud we work very closely
together these are two people that are
very close to my heart I've known them
both for a few years and I'm honored to
have them both here today thank you for
joining us
to hear it cloud next what are some of
the most exciting GCP tools that you've
been working with recently fantastic
well definitely our company runs on GCP
and I would kind of roll back and
reference there's a paper called the
Berkeley view about server lists so the
Dave Patterson paper really Eric Jonas
shout out to Eric and the whole team
they're my former boss and story etc
they did a paper like ten years ago
trying to describe what they thought
cloud was going to be you know after
about three years of use cases and I was
invited to comment on the paper and did
a guest lecture and that led to tools
like Apache spark like the grad students
who created spark we're in the audience
and we're talking about it and so ten
years of the day they have put together
another paper a lot again I mentioned
Eric Jonas doing I ran and I ran etc all
the work around ray and really try and
understand the fundamental economics of
how does service change this landscape
and so they're using server this is kind
of a bigger umbrella term you know it's
really thinking about the large-scale
services like I use cloud storage a lot
I used it a store these are kind of
things where I don't have to run a
server and so that complexity and state
is just off of our operations list and I
would reference that paper
it's like Robert you're doing go read
that page
there's really great blog post by young
historic comparing the two of them so
that's what I'm excited about I know the
the conference has just kicked off but
the highlight for me so far has been
having you moderate our session thank
you very kindly Thank You Michelle
and you all did a fantastic session
there I love the theme I love the big
reveal and the outcome following up from
the session to maybe we could talk about
that some - yeah I would love to hear
your favorite part of the session why
you think it's important and let's tell
people a little bit more about what that
big reveal was certainly well you know
there are really two parts of it really
popped out at me I mean obviously one is
just the richness of what's going on in
cube flow and what you can do especially
the auto-scaling parts that you demoed
really really fantastic work there I'm
learning more and more about this every
time I look but just the amount of
management of internal micro sources and
what's being exposed externally I've
been working a lot with workflow tooling
and so I was really happy to see what's
going on q flow but then in the context
also of like Quicksilver and what John
Bohannon and and their team at primer
has been doing the other part of this of
course was understanding human bias at
scale and looking at new sources
comparing that with Wikipedia and just
the fantastic work in highlighting where
there's bias but also how to fix it yeah
that's right they're doing some really
amazing things it was one of my favorite
projects to be able to take that amazing
and LP work and put it into Q flow it
combined two things that I'm just super
interested in so you have been pretty
busy recently
you're very well-known in the data
science space and have your own projects
now tell us a little bit about what
you've been working on sure I'm at a
company called Derwin and we do a lot of
machine learning work we haven't
announced it maybe I can just make the
big reveal on the podcast all right yeah
so you know we're doing a lot of work a
lot of tooling for
relations and particularly ways that
machine learning can be used in use
cases that are related to Deborah is
certainly taking a look at the whole art
of performance that's associated with
going out and speaking at conferences
meetups etc and a lot more teaching
tools I guess kind of go along with it
but with a focus toward the communities
that are engaged so we've been working
on that and we have a small team
together now and been pulling the other
clients and rolling out some products so
hopefully you all see more of that later
yeah that's amazing this is the best
location for you to be appreciated we've
been collecting data points of things
that we could improve and all of your
hard work will pay off I'm sorry I'm
wonderful
you know there's another project too I
could mention my colleague Ben Lorca
I had a Riley media we just got done
doing three large surveys so it was
really interesting it's what we're
calling ABC so AI big data and cloud and
we were looking at across the world
adoption for ABC and in particular
taking a contrast between companies that
are more mature maybe they've been doing
machine learning in production for like
five years versus companies that are
just yeah they've been it for a couple
of years they're figuring it out versus
companies that really haven't started
yet it's like what's the contrast
between those what do companies learn
once they start adopting cloud and
adopting a lot of the tooling and then
deploying machine learning and what are
some of the biggest surprises you found
in that survey was a couple things I
mean one is we were struggling with how
to understand investments in budget and
we had a multiple choice like are you
putting 5% of your IT budget toward
machine learning
tempers amplify and then we have this
catch fall at the end 20% or more or
like okay nobody's going to check that
and it turns out that when you look at
the mature practices they're really
doubling down so for 2019 43 percent of
enterprise said they're investing 20
percent or more of their total IT budget
into machine learning projects wow that
is a lot more than I expected yeah
startling and also just you know the
range just the kinds of applications
like half the organizations we surveyed
we're already using deep learning and a
third we're using some form of
human-in-the-loop active learning one
quarter were already working with
knowledge graph that kind of shocked me
this study I know there was a lot of
people from finance but we were
surprised to see one fifth saying that
they're starting to work with
reinforcement learning so portfolio
management is coming in but also
customer support and other areas and I
think the biggest thing when you look at
the gap between the mature companies in
machine learning versus the ones that
are still trying to figure it out
transfer learning is used at about 3x so
a really big bubble on transfer learning
Wow so as you see so many people
adopting this I mean 20% of IT budgets
at large companies in 40% that's serious
money that's serious money and something
like that can be quite dangerous if we
don't have the right safeguards in place
exactly kind of roll back a little bit I
was co-chair for Jupiter Khan and one of
the real surprises last year was in
project Jupiter a lot of the uptick was
enterprise and what we found is that
large organizations are rolling out open
source they're running either on pram
but more and more in the cloud or hybrid
in some way but they're using Jupiter
for infrastructure for data science so
teams can work together and executives
can see the results so that kind of
collaborative infrastructure based on
partly on Jupiter is also going back to
cube floats
very much part and parcel there we're
seeing it across the board and we were
really surprised that it was in the
regulated environments that there's more
of an uptick Capital One is really good
example 2 Sigma is another Wall Street
firm inside DoD Pay Pal you know Netflix
a lot of sort of digital infrastructure
is relying more and more and the thing
that struck out is like once you deploy
these kinds of collaborative tools and
you start working with data science
across the organization the things that
pop out are the business issues the
safety issues you're talking about it's
like how do we collaborate well as
opposed badly what are the security
issues what's the data privacy issues
what are the ethical issues and just the
whole spectrum of compliance that comes
in it's like as soon as you can get that
collaborative infrastructure out there
you come back to the human issues the
real business issues yeah and those are
really structures that we need to put in
place as humans to protect us from
things going wild and computers taking
over right yeah one thing that I've seen
over the past year or two in the field
is there's a lot of sort of debate about
friction or tension between data
engineering and data science it's a good
topic there's a lot of good issues there
to explore there there are some
companies to say you have to have five
data engineers for every data scientist
and then you go to stitch fix and
they're like no no no let's do the other
way around tower or even more right they
they have a lot of data scientists so
one thing there though we find is once
you deploy machine learning models in
production you get business issues that
come back to the real human element you
know models degrade once they hit live
customer data you have to figure that
out trying to understand why they're
acting differently than they did with a
training set is often a very challenging
statistical problem probably more
statistics than most data science teams
will have and it's also it's at that
point where you start hitting the
ethical issues bias issues that will
cause the regulators to come knocking
the other thing too is I'm helping
mentor someone over in London ICL a
researcher working on attack vectors for
deep learning and you know you can
inject a very tiny little bit of noise
and throw off models so the whole attack
surface is just really not well
understood yet and you take all of those
kind of safety factors into
consideration you you have to have the
right tool in you have to the right
process but you have to have the right
culture too one of the ways that you can
help is to have good data governance
policies you've been doing some work in
that space right yeah definitely I mean
that was something else that came out
the service was we asked what are your
priorities for investing in projects
where are you really focusing your
attention and of course in Enterprise
sort of what you would expect the double
you know data preparation feature
engineering these are hard problems
they're always going to be there at
least further than your future but then
you get down to like the fourth item in
the list and it was data governance
followed by metadata management followed
by lineage it was a bunch of governance
issues and so companies are really
taking this into account one thing I
didn't sure we were surprised by how
many enterprise companies have
checklists for ethics and bias and
privacy before you deploy so you know
companies are really taking to heart
they have to do the right thing or
they'll be in trouble so governance is
the larger issue there and governance
has been around since you know the 90s
and it was all sort of focused on data
warehouses in sequel for a long time but
I guess about 2012 you started to see
some of the first firms doing big data
data governance
halation I think was one of the early
ones and now you've got a real healthy
cohort of startups a couple of public
now
private equity has taken over a few that
are larger but it's it's a really
difficult thing to understand how do I
have a governance in the cloud versus on
pram versus at the edge the mobile apps
the data partnering that's going on it's
a super complex landscape and security
issues are becoming more and more
complex yeah I I don't think that
there's a lot of clear answers yet but
there are a lot of good questions it's
great to hear that companies have
preflight check lists I didn't realize
so many people were doing that and
that's definitely good to hear while
we're talking I can probably get some
numbers on that we would call it robust
model building checklists and definitely
there's this contrast where you see much
more emphasis on this image in mature
companies as opposed to the companies
are just starting to figure it out and
so I think that the industry is having a
pretty healthy reaction to some of
what's happened but but definitely Wall
Street Journal called 2018 I don't have
the exact language here it is basically
the total meltdown globally as far as
data governance I mean we had so many
breaches so many privacy problems that
involved in some cases hundreds of
millions of people in Asia there's very
noble one also you know things with
Facebook and elections and all the rest
it really brought to light how much we
have to take into account that our
governments forget yeah because as
platforms like Q flow make it easier to
spin up models we really have to be
careful about the types of models that
we release out into the world and what
we're doing with them and how we're
keeping track of where the data came
from that went into those models
although I think that there's a natural
pairing there I mean it sounds like the
emphasis on developing checklists and
developing culture around that could fit
very well with a lot of the process that
naturally comes out of keep flow and how
you
there are open-source projects like
dejan and others that try to integrate
some of this thinking into your
development and deployment process so
I'm hopefully these two kind of meet in
the middle
as we're looking and you're talking
about how people are spending budget
when you talk about checklist sets
processes when you talk about people and
resources and tooling how do you think
the most sophisticated advanced
companies are approaching splitting up
that budget between people processes and
tooling to be successful for all the
challenges and risks that you're seeing
approaching we tried to qualify and
quantify some the answers to this and I
put together a diagram that's basically
a survival analysis of that so if you
look at those three buckets that we're
using for our dimensions there's the
companies that are the leaders that are
more mature they've been getting return
on investment for machine learning for a
period of years already and then there's
companies are just kind of evaluating
there they're figuring it out they've
been in for years now but they still
struggle some and then there's a
company's probably 50% or more that are
real non-starters they don't get those
so I think it's in the survival analysis
if you will where you can see where the
budgets are effective and where they
aren't and so for the laggard group that
are non-starters they usually struggle
with tech debt and so that's one
characteristics that is pervasive their
data infrastructure has so much
technical debt that it's hard to get
accessibility to the data across
divisions so you still have a lot of
silos and that kind of goes back to the
original problem of data science
breaking down the silos the other two
points for the laggards are people
problems so one is a company culture
that doesn't recognize the need for
better get infrastructure or data
science for machine learning and that's
generally from the top Davos World
Economic Forum recognized that as one of
the crucial issues for Davos 2019 was
looking across the board begin board
and board members and executive staff
there where you run into problems where
they don't recognize the need for
machine learning they know that their
competitors are using it they know
regulators are going to ask difficult
questions they don't know how to
confront directly so yeah it's the
people problem of training education
what everyone say and the third point is
also a people problem a lot of companies
struggle with identifying business use
cases even if they're right in front of
them and so that's more matter of
awareness and learning about use cases
but it's kind of a product manager
problem so I would say that for the ones
that are really fumbling into 54% it
really does come down to tech debt
versus culture when you get into the
ones the mainstream companies that are
trying
what they find is talent gap so hiring
and that's the big people problem they
also have a lot of data quality issues
that are still struggling with that's
always going to be there but you know
there are priorities for where do you
put your investment do you launch a new
AI project do you do something else the
strategic what are the concerns gonna be
for security and other risks they kind
of struggle with those so those kind of
the three dimensions they're so related
to what you just talked about hiring is
hard so the people problems of being
able to find data scientists that are
experienced enough to understand the
full implications of the products that
they're building do you have any ideas
for ways we could put the proper
safeguards in place so like automated
ways of maybe teaching younger data
scientists and being able to be more
conscious of that very good question and
everybody's struggling with it
McKinsey and Deloitte and the rest are
publishing articles about how hard this
is and how much they're really
struggling you know I mean there are
definitely some excellent proofs like
Berkeley's program data 101 where
Berkeley now has data science programs
that are required for all undergraduates
that actually currently touch like 80
percent of the student population and
perfect wow isn't that any student or
just computer science across the board
the Chancellor came in and said thou
shalt have data science as a requirement
and oh by the way build out conduits
into social studies into part sciences
everywhere Wow
so that's good it's something that
requires a lot of infrastructure at
scale it's not sure how that percolates
down to Kansas State University or you
know I don't mean to pick on them I
actually like Manhattan Kansas but
there's a lot of other schools that
maybe don't have a hundred IT people on
staff like Berkeley Wood so that's a
question of how do we love that playing
field does the NSF get in and sort of
cookie cutter successful programs across
the board there have been studies about
the contrast of how Canada has tried to
roll out pervasive data science
education versus how the US has and the
story is in the u.s. it's really more
concentrated in the big schools Canada
was a little bit more uniform about it
in general I would lean more towards for
the people who are working right now and
need to be really conscious of the
problems we have today about ethics
about bias about how we're using data
about security they can't really afford
to stop everything and go get a
bachelor's degree right so I would
reference Amy Heinicke one of our
friends who you know had the great
phrase data science is a team sport and
so I think that if you go through that
lens where there's a lot of people who
are going to be working with these kind
of systems and problems and I don't even
call myself a data scientist I think
that a lot of people work in teams where
these are the kinds of tooling and
issues process that we have and a lot
more people need to be brought to speed
on how to participate in a team but the
thing that's been the real success out
of data science is the diversity is the
fact that it's inherently
interdisciplinary and having people with
you know radically different views of
the workplace working side-by-side or
how you knock down the hard problems
that would have been siloed otherwise so
I think I would be in favor of how can
people learn these skills and super
excited to see the uptick in Python the
uptick in Jupiter a lot of very
accessible tooling to get very
professional work done as part of my
talk I've mentioned I showed coop flow
running Jupiter and I mentioned that the
very first time I saw a Jupiter notebook
was in Paco's workshop that was
everything I learned about notebooks I
have you to thank for that thank you
kindly I'm very happy about what's been
going on in the in the Jupiter community
and there's great mentoring programs
that are adjacent to this some of what's
happened out of what's now called the
carpentras but basically mentoring
programs for teaching people in research
and then teaching them how to teach
other people in research and I think
that you know by and large mentoring is
a requirement for data science
especially in enterprise the techniques
go stale very quickly you have to be
doing continuous learning and part of
the way you do that as professionals to
build up your network of people who can
help you learn what's important and the
best way to do that is to mentor so if
you're out in industry right now and you
want to know how to build it this kind
of capability in your organization look
at the mentoring programs because it's
also a big win for diversity and
inclusion it's a healthy thing for
organizations and I think it's it's
really the the only answer given the
numbers who talk about training for data
science I agree there I know my career
has really been transformed once I found
great female mentors especially in the
data science space I love how you
mentioned the team sport aspect in the
cross collaborative aspect for bringing
people up to the next level I think it's
interesting how both of you were talking
about training at the academic level and
training at the beginning of people's
careers or churches employee transition
voids for their careers but as you
addressed a lot of the risks and
challenges people were facing Paco I
think you were talking more about where
companies have top-down management or
have hierarchical organizations and have
teams that operate and do
decision-making that way and for some
organizations and verticals that works
very well how do we look at and give
advice for people as they're thinking
about transforming their organizations
to be more reactive and proactive when
issues come up as to how they shape the
organizations to be able to work in this
active learning and this leveling space
where they're really facing the
challenges head-on rather than waiting
for someone to come tell them they have
a problem you
and to support this mentoring model and
really just proactively getting after
these challenges
yes exactly an across organization it's
not just with a data science team but
with the entire business decision-making
system that exists within a company so
there's a kind of a catch phrases being
used in industry now called the
unbundling of decision making and it's
the idea that okay top-down worked in
some places top-down decision making but
now we're finding that enterprise
organizations are large their very first
their distributed you can't rely on
top-down control structures so you have
to more collaborative ways of teams to
arrive at decisions and part of that is
also just the influx of machine learning
now we have teams of people and machines
so how do we manage that there's a
really fantastic article about it from a
Agarwal on was on McKinsey quarterly
it's called the economics of artificial
intelligence but it really unpacks that
notion of unbundling of decision making
and also I believe somebody at Google
chief decision scientist for Google
cloud because he chose Rob really
fantastic work her lectures that I've
done catch a couple of those also about
sort of decision engineering and how
what Cassie was showing is Google is
coming out and saying hey look we've
learned from some mistakes and this is
really a better way I think that's an
important thing you have because what
better touch-tone could you reference
for using AI than Google but yet
organizations still have to learn yeah
Cassie is one of our favorite colleagues
were very lucky to have her she's part
of our group called fantastic and I
think it goes back to conversations it's
funny you're talking michele about your
introduction Epoque oh my introduction
to Paco was a shared interest in control
systems and complex systems so we had a
lot of conversations around how initial
data sides pipelines were designed
around DAGs and direct acyclic graphs
which did not actually take into account
feedback loops and it sounds now like
we're progressing to that point where we
can get both systems design as well as
the computational design to be able to
incorporate decisive loops within there
to be able to allow humans and machines
to be able to question decision points
along the way I find that very
encouraging and fascinating
you know there's kind of three
dimensions there I think there are
feedback loops that are inherently
two-way streets if done right and they
involve the people in your organization
who have a deep bench of the use cases
they have institutional learning and
they train other people to come in
riotous again getting back to the team
sport aspect there's the models which
are being updated but curated and then
there's also the customers and so there
is interaction between the customers and
the models right in your product but
also between your people and your
customers and also there's an erection
between your people and the models so
how can you engineer or really
facilitate those kind of feedback loops
in a way that's very beneficial for all
involved and I think that was the point
of your talk today michelle was looking
at where decisions happen inside of a
very complex system and then trying to
make sure that you understand when your
outcome is not reflective of a more
holistic structure how do you add
something to that system so that it can
make better outcomes that is more
representative of the people in the
population the customers that you want
to serve yeah that's right I mean I
think so many times we sort of blame ml
for coming up with these bias outcomes
but the models are subject to the data
that we feed into them and it takes
human decisions to overcome that to
build the type of model that can work
around that bias that can accommodate it
if we never make human decisions to do
that then we'll get the same outcomes
ever
so it is very much a human problem we
can't blame the machines humans are
creating the code that creates this and
all of that data is based on generations
of human bias and it's up to us to look
at things from a different perspective
and to take an active role in changing
that the in your talk you were
discussing about structural bias and how
some of this is so subtle and nuanced
you can't really point to here's rule
531 that causes the problem but instead
is this interaction of a lot of complex
rule systems that we just delegate to
and that in large quantities at scale
that's what leads to the really terrible
cases of bias
yeah that's right these these little
small things accumulate when you're
talking about just a small group of
people it's not always obvious or maybe
it is but when you extrapolate out to
millions of people that's where it just
becomes very glaring and it excludes
whole groups of people and you can use
machine learning to identify that in a
way that as a human you couldn't you can
use machine learning to sort of tease
out what those examples are and then use
it to help you build something that
accommodates that but these are all
human decisions it's very much a cop-out
to blame machine learning for being
biased when were the ones who are
building these systems who are coming up
with the concepts and using them to
solve very specific problems we're the
ones defining those problems and we're a
part of that system then so when we
define ourselves as separate from it
we're trying to remove responsibility
from the decisions we're making along
the way getting back to the control
system yes but if we inject ourselves
back as a node into that decision-making
process when we find that there are
errors or problems the solution to that
may not always be more data better data
different data it may not be a different
component in the algorithm it may be
that you have to allow trust for users
or customers or yourself the people who
are creating those systems in a place
that back into a large distributed
network and being able to identify that
and identify what is the right problem
that you're trying to solve is the
answer a person is the answer
an algorithm adjustment or is it answer
a different computational structure it's
very important and I think we're
reaching a good stage where we can start
to make those blended answers as opposed
to always looking for a different
parameter value to fix in the shuttle so
I really like what you're describing I
think it's important to think of machine
learning supervised machine learning not
just as a way to predict but as a lens
and so can we use it as a lens to
understand contrast and then begin to
understand our own structural bias ease
more that's something that is probably
not taught in courses about machine
learning but I think as we dig more into
the real cultural problems that are
coming to light there will be well
Amanda you brought up a really great
point about control systems I think that
Margaret Mead probably is one of the
better authors in this area from like
6070 years ago can you say that name
again I didn't know Margaret Mead Oh
Marguerite anthropology studies leading
to second order of cybernetics the Macy
conferences really fantastic work back
there so I think that we need to look
back into our own history intellectual
history some of the bridges have already
been crossed can really inform the
social problems were running into now I
mean a lot of what we run into daily
about bias and problems in machine
learning you know Marshall McLuhan set
out this incredibly strange book called
the Gutenberg galaxy back in 1960 and
it's actually kind of hard to read but
really really fascinating to read but I
mean he just laid it out he like I could
tell here's where it's all gonna kind of
go sideways and you know he didn't even
live to see the Internet but he nailed
it so I think between Margaret Mead and
Marshall McLuhan and Russell and some of
the others there's a lot that we can
I think that there are there's a
wonderful reading lists that we can have
from historical technology murray hicks
book she wrote on programming inequality
and talking about looking at how women
were systemically taken out of an entire
industry in a country is very
eye-opening and wonderful for us to
understand how do these decisions
property and then even should you change
that initial decision point how does it
continue to move through these larger
distribution systems that the effects
are felt at a much larger time scale
than you originally understood they
would or could be I think those are
awesome use cases and historical
examples for us to be able to look at to
understand when we first started
automating decision systems we first
started creating things that we wanted
to make a little bit quicker controls in
order to be able to move us along with
machines when we had human machine
interactions how did those first
decisions get made what were the
implications of those when we change
that initial decision that was made how
did it continue to move through the rest
of our culture and which would we be
learning from that as we're looking at
creating systems that scale I love how
you talked about that Michelle that
we're giving the people tools to
automatically scale and globally scale
their systems globally scale their
products and we want to be able to do
that but we also want to be able to make
sure that we are keeping up with
responsibilities decision frameworks
along the way and computational tools
that will allow people to know when
those systems are being used responsibly
when they are I think as you're talking
about Paco when the respecters are being
examined appropriately or if people are
using them in a way they didn't
originally in that tend that system to
be used and letting the creators know
that as early as possible so that they
can take action on what's happening with
it and as much as possible trying to
bake that into the framework so that
it's just by default therefore everyone
as easily as the technologies that
enable for everybody right I love how
you say that because this is what cue
flow is is an open source project and we
want to make sure those frameworks are
available to all and just not a few
wonderful this has been amazing thank
you both for sitting down with us it has
been amazing having you both here thank
you for joining us
Paco Nathan from Derwin is there any
last things you'd like to plug oh no I'm
just I'm really looking forward to
wandering around here at next it's
really fascinating maybe kept some more
talks it's wonderful thank you again for
taking so much time out of your schedule
to join us here and thank you again
Amanda for joining us today this has
been one of the most fun podcast
episodes I've ever done to have two of
my friends all together talking data
science I really appreciate it what has
been the best part of next for you
Amanda
well this is my first next and so far
the best part for me has been seeing all
of the amazing hard work that I've seen
so many passionate people who really
care about creating things for
developers and creating things for our
customers and for really creating
tooling it will allow so many people to
just create whatever is in their mind to
create their dreams and to be able to
carry that out in a way where they don't
have to consider every small piece along
the way that may not be expert in but
that they're happy to get expertise and
help from other people so really
identifying and seeing all of these
individual pieces come together with
people and with hard work and their
releases it's just been so lovely and
fascinating and also just the amount of
I think culture and care for our
conference the intention ality that I've
seen all the organizers put into making
sure that it is an inclusive space for
people to come and ask questions and
talk to everybody that's here has been
wonderful thank you both for joining us
huge thank you to Paco and Amanda for
joining me at next I really enjoyed that
conversation I'm very happy to share it
so now to our question of the week
John stadia connect happened last
Thursday what are some of the biggest
announcements that came out of it I'm
pretty excited about this because I've
been sitting on a little bit of the
information for a while but you know we
couldn't publicly release this
information but you know it's always
good to have that stadia the way I've
always described it as being like the
Netflix of video games and you can
imagine that your resolution scales
based on your connection and stadia does
the same thing and one other thing that
developers always access at our gaming
conferences is what is the speed
necessary to render in 4k in the data
centers and you just need at least 35
megabytes per second which I don't think
it's too bad because I think that's
around the typical amount of dung that
you get when your ISPs which is kind of
Awesome and it's only requires a minimum
of 10 megabytes per second which is
awesome so at 10 megabytes you'll get
seven ATP and you'll get I believe
regular stereo sound and at the highest
you'll get 5.1 surround sound also a
bunch of games were announced as well
I'm pretty excited about a bunch of them
and a lot have been announced at e3 this
week so just some notable names I'm
excited about Final Fantasy 15
Assassin's Creed Odyssey is what's been
seen at our demos the division 2 looked
amazing when they showed it off and one
of the things that I think will be a
really big hit in the home would be just
dance so that'd be kind of cool and the
last thing is they kind of announced the
stadium founders Edition Bundle it comes
with a 4k chromecast and a stadia
controller it's a special edition
controller so you can only get this as
an exclusive when you get the founders
Edition and it comes in blue which is
kind of cool but I'm personally more
excited about the black one and there
actually was one more announcement they
talked about price that was one of the
big things that people wanted to know
about and for Stadio Pro is it'll cost
you $9.99 a month which isn't too bad
that's around the same amount that you
will pay for your typical streaming
service and there also is a free tier
but that will be coming next year and a
lot of these features and a lot of these
products will be coming out and launch
in I believe in November so I'm really
excited for that to come out that's a
lot of announcements thanks for sharing
I'm super excited about it
I
right I think that wraps us up for this
week so where are we all going to be
this week I know I'm back on my home
turf in San Francisco after my long trip
to Geneva in Barcelona where will you be
John well I'll be in New York the next
conference I'm actually turning is games
for change we talked about it a little
bit in my last episode with mark but
just to remind our listeners what that
is it's pretty much a conference where
developers are creating games for change
as in the title but has a lot of social
impact games breaking down the barriers
between diversity and you know being
more inclusive in games and developers
who were really focused on that gets a
showcase those things and I get to
actually attend a couple talks to see
the momentum shift to actually making
these changes in games so I'm pretty
excited to be attending that so that
will be occurring for me next week
yeah the week of the 17th yeah so I'm
pretty excited sounds great I think most
of us are at home and a mark mission
Donnie will be here in San Francisco
Brian and Asha will be in Seattle and
Gabby's I believe she'll be in Brazil
this week I just saw her off last week
so she's really excited to go home and
see it not only a family but she's
attending a couple conferences there as
well yeah I've been to Brazil with Gabby
and she's in her element when she's down
there very excited for her and jealous
but I'm not in Brazil I've been in South
America but I'm really really really
wanting to go to Brazil
so hopefully Gabby will take me along
one day I recommend it a great place
well thank you all for listening and
we'll hope to see you next week good bye
thanks John
[Music]